le verdict est tombé khaled rahmouni
écope d'une peine de deux ans de prison
ferme suite à son jugement en appel
un coup de massue pour le journaliste
algérien derrière les barreaux depuis
près de six mois
symbole du combat pour la liberté de la
presse en algérie
il lui est reproché de porter atteinte à
l'unité nationale le 10 août dernier
le reporter de 40 ans avait été condamné
une première fois à trois ans de prison
pour incitation à un attroupement noir
mais ses avocats ne compte pas en rester
là
deux ans de prison ferme pour de rares
eni nous allons faire un pourvoi en
cassation après cette condamnation des
centaines d'algériens ont manifesté leur
mécontentement dans les rues de la
capitale pour eux ce verdict est
beaucoup trop sévère
il se montre pessimiste sur l'avenir de
leur pays
je trouve que c'est abusé
aujourd'hui
elle consacre l'injustice
au sein du palais de justice c'est juste
immoral non éthiques
et cela n'augure rien de bon pour la
suite de l'avenir de l'algérie
si triste aujourd'hui un journaliste qui
a exercé son métier qui a fait ses
fonctions de journaliste qui n'a fait
que transmettre la voix du peuple
ce trop condamné de deux ans de prison
c'est quoi ça moi je pense aujourd'hui
qu'on ne peut plus exercer le
journalisme d'angers on en algérie
aujourd'hui on ne fait que date chargé
de communication du régime
un vent de colère en algérie mais aussi
sur les réseaux sociaux où
l'organisation reporters sans frontières
et son secrétaire général dénonce la
décision de la cour d'alger
nous sommes scandalisés par l'entêtement
aveugle des juges algériens qui viennent
de condamner khaled rariny à deux ans de
prison
son maintien en détention est la preuve
d'un enfermement du régime dans une
logique de répression absurde injuste et
violente
il y a quelques semaines le gouvernement
algérien se défendent en affirmant que
khaled rares et ni pratiquer sans carte
de presse professionnelle
problème aucune commission délivrant de
carte nationale le journaliste
professionnelle n'existe dans le pays et
aucun journaliste travail en algérie
nan posséderait d'après les défenseurs
du reporter condamné en attendant de
nouvelles manifestations sont attendues
ces prochains jours en soutien aux
journalistes
désormais le plus célèbre d'algérie